tout excusé sur deux se trouvent sur by
the kind of et on avait honte vous avez
fait une vidéo tu à l'époque et là le
jeu est sorti on a anticipé sur steam
avec un peu plus de contenu du coup j'ai
envie de taper des genres brutalité ah
ça fait plaisir d'être de retour et
arrêter tous me regarde et vous savez
que j'en ai marre vous savez que ça me
plaît pas du tout est-ce que tu le sais
toi c'est parti bloor timone pam de
bière a tant pis s'il est en train de se
battre il avait rien demandé il était
totalement outre que je vienne
l'embrouillé quoi ta ta ta ta peu
bouveret moi je pense que les médecins
auraient causé ce jeu à tous les gens
qui ont des gros problèmes dans leur vie
qu'ils sont très frustrés par exemple
kim est tombée en dépôt sur youtube ces
profondeurs équipe et il est sage alors
toi mais tu me suit depuis 20 minutes
avec ta chaise voilà fallait que ça
cesse un jour arrêter à la fin d'été les
revend aux [ __ ] bien pistolet à
l'hôtital loser va acheter saute dessus
matin alors choix qu'on avait des
pouvoirs spéciaux à utiliser je crois
est vrai dit c'est quoi ça oh c'était ce
qu'il a mais mais mais à l'été
est-ce que vous voyez c'est une campagne
de pub de l'éducation nationale en fait
par contre c'est la russie qui m'a
demandé ça et vu que je fais ça pour la
france un peu bizarre semblable à face
et ouais moi je fais partie de
l'imaginaire hagens tu vois [ __ ] je
vais faire jean c'était pas moi je te
vois raté c'est pas moi c'est pas moi
c'est pas moi c'est pas moi c'est pas
moi c'est pas moi je peux prendre ça au
sérieux a fait chier au but frustré
pardon mais elle est là willy cuisse
tous a tempêté le mec qui se regarde on
écoute au genou tout est beau tout est
beau tout est chaud toilettes du viendra
pas tu peux occupa [ __ ] les gars optex
marché à tous chez soi faire affaire en
embuscade au regard des plats
ça le tuba pas mais pas ses employés au
lit accolades dans homère dit le mafieux
du bar l'accusé l'accueil de la cuisine
hockey jacques à ce qu'on te revoir là
je vais débuter à temps mais l'avancé
blocus travail tu attends c'est abusé
quoi oh c'est bon
la chute au couteau mais s'est prononcé
pour garder le doubs tout seul plus de
failles co op l'art j'étais bien steak
au plage de viard steak me barre je me
marre je me marre je me barre je me bats
à ces enjeux de monnaie dans un bar trop
marrant
oh [ __ ] mais tu peux tu apportes n'y a
pas le temps pardon pardon pardon pardon
j'ai occupé est ce qu'il y avait là-bas
je voulais pas y aller ou les galets
gallega au matin il a un couteau
oh non non non [ __ ] mais c'est la
mafia ici à tence a rien fait le mais
les mecs c'est décidé mais bon vous
savez quoi sert des cils deuxième niveau
c'est une boîte de nuit choix salut les
gars ses groupies pas [ __ ] c'est super
joli abuser c'est pas moi c'est pas moi
c'est pas moi c'est pas moi c'est pas
moi alors le dj jack va se calmer puis
j'en ai marre sillage voilà on va là
haut up issue de secours
non non à vélo la dépense était dans
l'urinoir aulas lui faut pas l'énerver
je pense du coup on va aller vers des
eaux oui on te doutes à kde
elle est trop bien la musique mon gars
abusé je suis trop bien là shockwave
really the prize mandats locaux
voilà attend également une contreuse
soirée dans les toilettes
laisse moi mon année y'a pas un
lance-roquette sinon si on fait il
yad'autres pouvoir regarder il ya
berserk et smite moi je veut se marier
mais faut remplir les trois bars salut
je veux tout baigne ok mais qui m'a tuer
qu'intel larmes la plus nulle du bar et
ret s'est lui attaché lui prend le
panier au jeu des tuyaux peigne quoi
avec son père à celle ultra millions ok
on a la moitié la première barre je veux
vraiment voir ce que ça fait smite aulas
on secrète bon gars et venait d'appeler
la coi à toi bulls alors là on n achète
mon gars et je parle pas de l'éditeur de
bouquins
regardez katana ok moi le boss a pris
aux catalans restent à faire - de
tutelle lui l'effort lui au masters va
se faire vous en faites pas on va y
arriver il va jamais mûri et la possible
au poste du par boga sans déconner on
lui aussi cacher un truc terre tu me
l'avais pas dit [ __ ] un peu violent
cela était parti à baisser le truc que
j'avais dans la démo je suis déçu à tous
tes tu as eu des balles de snipers
regarder non c'est quoi ça oh mon regard
je vais en mettre partout au carat on
peut parler des aliens c'est incroyable
mec c'est incroyable non t'as pas fait
sur j'aime bien le concept à des enjeux
c'est dingue et sa verve est sûre qu'il
faille le faire c'était chef des accusés
comment on fait on va dans le bureau de
yakuza mon gars c'est résiste au rayon
l'ex intéressés à buzet tube price
mauvaise foi comme ça va le but est ou
pas
[Musique]
quoi non il reste ce pack non mais c'est
une blague là vient tuable regardez le
il est un tueur ce bâtard mais non mais
non mais non
et j'ose dire 30 cette vidéo sur pen
obtiendrait d'un accès anticipé et ben
la nouvelle map est très cool là dans le
disco embuscade yakuza qu'on a
totalement explosé
c'est super n'hésitez pas aimé la vidéo
ça vous a plu on s'est tous retrouvés
dans une prochaine et moi j'adore ce jeu
sa véritable défouloir en plus il est
beau tout est beau ça veut rien dire
parce que de toute évidence une
prochaine vidéo merci à maria riesch all
hope is
[Musique]